bye
this year I am at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study where I'm
completing my book on firing line which
was William F Buckley juniors public
affairs show that ran on PBS from
nineteen sixty six to nineteen ninety
nine my Buckley was a key figure in
pushing the extremist I'm a conservative
movement and forging a more mainstream
image for right-wing conservatism its
firing line premiered in 1966 at a
moment when people thought liberalism
had really one in America he created the
show in large part to debate with
liberal guests to put liberals and left
wingers on the firing line it's the name
of the show and to show what a proper
right-wing conservative response would
be to the left and to liberals so if you
watch the show from 66 to 80 which is in
many ways the Golden Age of the show you
see him encounter um so many of the key
liberals and left for years of that era
it's astounding the people like Betty
for example in women's liberation
movement a Huey P Newton and Eldridge
Cleaver from the Black Power movement ah
Nixon was on the show before he was
president reagan was on the show several
times Barry Goldwater was on the show
Victor Navasky the former editor of the
nation and so you really get to see the
encounter between left and right over
this period um as the country started
veering more to the right people who
were later not obscure we're on the show
when they were asked y for example a
very young marine named Oliver North was
on the show shortly after the meal I'm
her mother or debates over war crimes
happening in Vietnam or you could have
mr. Buckley a Marine general or an army
general come down here on this show and
tell you what his specific waters were
when he was occur or you could have a
lieutenant Karl come up and tell you and
I think it would be massively
disbelieved because here's a man who in
the eye of the public because of the way
this thing has been presented his trying
to cover his his tail if I'm to use the
vernacular with paper I think I'd want
to go on the set of firing line and
watch it happening live um I'm not sure
which episode is there are so many good
ones the show's often start with a
camera moving over the crowd a couple of
great episodes one with Timothy Leary
and one with the filmmaker Otto
Preminger shot with students from Queens
College asking a really great question
movie do you plan in the future to use
these means to uh to settle with
present-day problems let's say not let's
say as in the Cardinal you dealt with
Nazism know what do you plan to deal
with let's say communism if I have a
chance yes you know I would like to make
a film what are you waiting for mm-hmm
what are you waiting well it's story you
see I make films I basically needed the
car dealer was a personal story however
I chose freedom well my famous thing
whether you're politically to the left
or the right or more towards the center
I think you can really learn a lot from
thinking about lame F Buckley from
looking at his program because it was a
space where left and right could have
honest debate um sometimes it was clear
who would one often it was not clear who
had one you can watch it as a liberal
and learn about liberalism you can watch
this conservative and learn about
conservatism and what I am and learn
about Buckley's idea of what true
conservatism was um Andy was of a moment
when political debate was not driven by
sound bites um there was real discussion
these were hour-long show
and so in a cable news environment like
we have now it's hard to find that kind
of extended debate people get a minute
to be a talking head and move on to the
next person not to the cable news is
divided politically so that you have the
liberal station the conservative station
you know Fox News MSNBC and a firing
line is set for than such a different
picture of how we can debate politics
how we think about politics and how we
can listen to each other on the left and
right
Oh
you